I love rom-coms and it's so wonderful to
have you both in this are you a big fan
of rom-coms
yes oh yeah I think so yes we are right
yes
yeah I'm from Canada are you so I can
speak the language you can speak the
language she said she can speak the
language uh you know uh yesterday was a
big night for you and to be releasing
this film with Jennifer Lopez what was
it like for you to be working with the
queen and you're the queen do hey they
no you know um no she really is the
queen and uh she really is and you know
I have to say we we did have a lot of
fun we've had a it was a very cool group
of people down and we shot in the
Dominican Republic and it was yeah
um we were all living together in the
same mind-blowing compound
um and we had like a swimming pool that
looked it was like a lake and and the
you know the crashing waves and all this
stuff so it had a lot of drama to it but
it was you know every night at dinner it
was like you know the same like you know
like eight actors
Lenny Kravitz was at dinner every night
um you know it was pretty uh
what did he sing no he never did no he
never did he was stupid no you wouldn't
have known it was a bunch of actors and
a rock star because everyone just talked
about life and things yeah you wouldn't
yeah it was pretty it was very normal
and nice it was yeah yeah and then Lenny
would uh sometimes like late at night he
would come to the table with a his
ghetto blaster and then play us the best
dance tunes and we all oh we did we all
did dance dance in the garden dance our
dinner off I love that you know what
makes a good wedding because there's a
lot of Chaos in this and there's you
know a lot of venture going on but what
makes a a good wedding
I think I want to start with
whoever gives the speeches
you have to really pick those people
really yeah I'm really here you know
that you have to really pick the
charismatic funny person or whatever to
give the speech I mean you did an
incredible speech yesterday I mean Brad
Pitt was completely enthralled I mean I
would hire you to do a wedding hey
thanks you would do a good wedding stuff
yeah you should have been we didn't have
anybody in my wedding but you could have
come and talked I know but Steve I
wasn't invited to Steve's wedding no one
was invited it was just three of us
three of us two of us
I would have gone I would have spoken at
that wedding
I know you know and I gotta say I
Jennifer I'm just loving you right now
and everything that you're doing and and
even you Stephen but you were just on
the piece
um are you are you feeling it are you
feeling this high right now
hi
um all right she said are you high yeah
I am so high right now this is a probing
interview no
no that doesn't get around no you know
what I you know the thing is
if it had happened earlier in my life
anything like you know it happened
earlier in my life I I wouldn't feel
this high but you see it was the
surprise is this such an unexpected
moment that I would never have predicted
in a million years so that's what makes
it fun when you don't you know you know
what I mean like because you've already
I'd already mapped out how it was going
to go and it wasn't going to go well so
I am thrilled thrilled that this moment
is happening yes I mean I don't think
anyone can Reign on it yeah nobody can
and Steve and I are both big fans of
Legally Blonde and I know the Legally
Blonde Three is coming out uh Ariana
Grande needs to be part of it because
you acknowledged her and you said Thank
you to her and that makes it so special
yeah I really I I love that girl and um
yeah and she has so much sheet now look
I mean she her life she's at the
beginning of her life and it's like uh
she is someone that is such an unusual
story because she's this
very very old person in a very young
body young age body I mean it's really
weird I sometimes feel like I'm talking
to
like
I'm talking to someone ancient or take
or like her just the way she can her
take on things and everything is so
Advanced I don't know I don't really
know how to explain to her I've never
met anyone like her in my life I love it
and nobody's met someone like you too
you are absolutely amazing you too
Stephen congratulations because this is
a rom-com everyone will be talking about
so thank you thank you